today's topic there was a big big reveal
evidence from the Andrew Tate trial got
leaked dealer somewhere and essentially
conversations that he had in his place
called the War Room which was like
um it used to be his course that he
would basically sell people on to make
lots of money and he would have private
conversation with these people telling
them
this is instructional on how to
manipulate women into doing X work for
his works so lesmina who's one of the
trafficking victims in the
um case against Andrew Kate the legal
one as well as Georgina uh who's his BB
which is bottom bit okay and bottom
is basically the woman beneath the
pimp who helps recruit the other women
and keep them in line because women
trust other women a lot more a lot of
men will use these kinds of women to
manipulate women okay so this is the
conversation not my words you're gonna
read it update on the two girls living
together so they became good friends
everything was stable the girl who Moved
lost her Support Network at home
cemented her move talking about sting
forever can't wait for me to come back
Etc essentially this girl moved from
somewhere else to come live with Andrew
she lost a lot her family Network back
home as a result okay
so Andrew says so I had to tighten the
screw so I said somebody in her Old Town
told me she worked in a sex club I
literally made this up from the sky
started calling her a liar and
threatening to kick her out but the real
goal is for her to agree to never go
anywhere without me not even her
hometown I need her working not visiting
friends back in her hometown so putting
nails in that coffin saying but saying
um people are talking bad about her so
basically what he's doing in this
conversation is he's working towards
isolating her from her loved ones her
friendly and fans so she can never go
back and she has to rely on him for
everything yep okay so this is the
conversation that he had with Jasmina
privately through WhatsApp you worked in
a sex club I did not work in a sex club
I'm not lying where did you get this out
from so you'd rather believe them so she
really believes other people are talking
about her I told you the truth
these people want me no good I don't
know who you have talked to but I've
only slept with four men in my life and
you were one of them I have never lied
to you you said it yourself that people
will try to destroy us break us apart
I've heard things too but I choose to
believe you and not them well probably
sure to believe those things I asked you
answer me please and tell me this is a
joke because I really don't want to
believe that you mean what you're saying
I'm freaking crying alone in a room and
you think I'm not serious I'm tired of
this so-called friends acting like
friends and ruining my chances to be
happy and it hurts that you believe that
where am I now Andrew here why because I
am serious Andrew replies serious Girls
Don't Lie yes I understand she says you
are not going back to tismor even to
visit without me you understand
so he tismore is where she's from her
hometown he said basically she told him
you're never going back and she says yes
I understand
my people there are telling me you
talked to tons of men and worked in a
sex club I'm not having you go back
there for them to call me and tell me
more she replies that's a lie but
as I said earlier look at me Andrew
replies you don't need to leave the
house in Bucharest without either me or
Georgina we are together always so this
is how he's socially isolated her let's
go to part two updates on the two girls
living together if anyone doesn't know
the story ask the guys here to find out
for you so I told my girl to send me a
picture she said this all right so that
he puts a screenshot of what she wrote
to him she writes at the same time I
have a few things very few but rules I
can't break because I'm old-fashioned
and I still believe in God one I never
sent a picture of me in lingerie ever I
made a promise to God and myself and I
will keep it two I will never do video
chatter only fans because my body's
intimate and I only want my husband
should be able to touch and see three if
I give you my love I'm expecting the
same thing back for the man I love
should not hit or beat me up this is it
if these four things are respected when
it comes to me then there's no way we
can ever fight I listen when I have to
I'm quiet when I'm supposed to and I'm
definitely dedicated on being a good
wife waking you up in the morning with
fresh coffee and a meal all yours and
forever this is the way I was raised had
this on my heart the whole day so I had
to say it you are the perfect man for me
and the man I've been dreaming to meet
and have a family with since I was a kid
now it's your turn to decide if the
things change the way you see me or if
I'm still the woman you want to spend
your life with I do do you
so basically she's saying
don't meet me out to be a and
don't beat me up those are her
requirements which I think most men
watching think that's reasonable
Andrew's goal is he flies these women
out he makes them fall in love with him
he uses sex as a manipulation tool for
his words don't not me I use sex as a
tool to make women love me so they'd
obey me and live in my house and make me
money that that's what I wanted so yeah
on corporate.com I have my PhD program
and that is uh PhD is a Pimpin hoes
degree that um
that teaches basically how I got girls
how I met girls how I got girls to like
me how I got girls to fall in love with
me to work on webcam for me uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together work for
you doing what so you'll have a webcam
business oh I don't want to do that it's
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't do it fine but let me
explain it to you properly in fact I'll
bring one of the girls who works for me
your Bolton is the one who does
the selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where your bottom has to be
trained so I said it's so important to
have a good first girl because that's
what I did that was my my Mo was fine
girls make them love me and make them
work for me and then these were women
who've never done adult work they've
never been interested in doing adult
work but he would find ways to isolate
them from their friends and family make
them go broke and then try to get them
into the cam business so he can make a
profit off them so regardless if even
though whether you think that's legal or
not it's got to be some evil
to isolate somebody from their friends
and family just so you can make
financial gain this video is brought to
you by surfshark no matter where I'm at
all right whether it's in my house or in
my Airbnb when I'm away or in Antarctica
or or even when I'm thinking of I
need to have access to all my programs
hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in yeah and
for that I need a system that allows me
to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
Surfside you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have three months extra free
I know crazy get on it so in response to
this message though he says this sounds
like a hard target for cams or only fans
right so let's take bets will I get her
to work Anonymous poll so basically he's
asking the people in the group chat do
you think she's gonna get to work for me
after seeing that message and one of the
guys replies yeah that isolation is
critical I have no experience in this
realm but I would try to be good cop bad
cop this is from Mac J one of the people
who are part of the War Room
I act deeply hurt by her refusal flip it
on her and get her to start feeling
guilty or cry then have my BB bottom
ask why she's upset tell her how
religious she used to be and how easy
fun camping is again never had to do
anything like this but maybe it works
and then Tate replies close
I'm actually going to add a layer of
Separation I will use Geo Georgina as
the bottom and pretend I don't
care either way she can attack me for
tricking her she looks super adamant
about not doing this she even made
bullet points I still bet yes because
you're a top G but it would be super
impressive to see it in action
so basically these guys are just
discussing how they're going to traffic
these women and get him to do the camera
well as a as a course right there's a
course to it but this group chat is just
private for the select few one of the
human traffickers I guess and have girls
do cam for them so Tate in this says
another element since she's moved she's
been fed but nothing else she's broke
she can't go home she can't leave the
house man I almost sound evil but I'm
not I'm a Shepherd leading the Sheep
take holds on to say
so now I know she's broke and I know
what I believe the objections to be my
plan is to use Georgina as a bottom
to convince her I don't give a
if she camps but the only way she
will have serious money is if she does
isolate her from her friends and family
make her dependent on you give her a
food and tell her the only way she can
make money is if she does the caming
stuff because she's not allowed to leave
the house without you so he asks her
let her Panic a little bit remember she
asks for money now that's scary for her
and I'd come back with yes we need to be
together but every girl Romania asks me
for money I know you're not like them
are you make her Qui make her qualify
herself as not a gold digger and she
says no no no I'm not I'm not then come
in with we're going to be traveling
together I'm working from home my phone
we're gonna we're gonna we're a team
you're gonna listen to me and work from
your phone too
send her a pic of an Ibiza Beach Ibiza
is an island if you're unaware and
because cam has been soft floated before
I'd go for a hard close if outrage if
outright refused don't reply let her sit
broke to think so basically she don't
reply to the offer she's not down then
don't reply and make her worry because
she's in love with you one of the guys
writes statism in a sentence it's all
beautiful a beautiful full game of chess
so these guys are in a group chat really
bragging about manipulating women into
that's nerd
this is her talking to Georgina the
ex-cop who's his bottom you have
said my job was to meet a girl go on a
few dates sleep with her get her to fall
in love with me to the point where she'd
do anything I say and then get her on
webcam so we could become rich together
I don't think that's what I personally
said I think that's exactly what you
said on your website that's no I've
never said that okay so
that's the general gist of the
conversations considering everything
else we've seen from this guy in regards
to some of the stuff he set what do you
think
well a lot of videos I've seen about him
and the interviews that I've seen he's
denying everything yeah
uh it's very weird it's easily provable
like is it because you're trying to say
face or whatever or you're trying to
I don't know I don't know
we don't know but
um
he did say that in his chat on his
website on courses that he has like they
took computers even if you delete
something off your computer they have
ways to retrieve all that stuff right so
it it it's it's
not really looking good because that's
just one thing that got out right and
they're not just basing themselves on
that they they got they got way more and
it's not just
when I first I thought it was one
country it's not one country it's
actually three countries
that are talking about that it's like
it's it's a lot to matter just when one
country's against you and you you've
been talking about that country
when three are working together to take
you down
amen
yeah I'll say this
um those conversations from what I
understand have been authenticated I
guess is part of what dicot the people
who are Prosecuting uh Tate found and
there's probably way way more of that
since this leaked only now yeah the fact
that they have that is very talent for
me that looks like textbook manipulation
and fraud the fact that he was eye on
offer these women marriage with the old
sole intention of turning them into
webcam workers the things and the
tactics he was using to isolate them
from friends and family in order to make
sure he could brainwash them yeah and
absolutely he's taking young and
impressionable women for that very
reason I have no problem this Falls
right under the textbook definition the
Loverboy method before I was like 80
sure he's guilty now I'm 100 sure when
I've seen messages like these and people
can't say oh Abba you don't know if it's
a character or if he really did that
so what even in private
conversation this guy's also making it
up some of you guys gotta stop coping
y'all want to talk about the fact that
women aren't very logical you guys are
bending over backwards breaking the real
boundaries of reality just to believe
something you want to believe it's fine
to say Tate was a good influence in your
life and he offered you good advice I
don't even mind it's very possible
that's true what is the possibility it
doesn't change the fact that the two
things can be true at the same time he
was good for you in terms of your
development as a man he said some true
things and two three he's a sex
trafficker
and everything I've heard from his own
mouth his own private conversations
tells me that's what he is all right
Kelly you made some banging beats he
peed on underage people
a lot of people in the comments were
talking about
yeah but why are we going after him uh
when other companies and other people
have been doing that the difference with
him is that he's not only doing that
with other people but monetizing his
tactics to do that to other people which
makes it worse people are going to want
to crack down on that you understand
what I'm saying it makes it even worse
it's worse that you're trafficking
people but you're monetizing not only
the trafficking but you're monetizing
the fact that hey let me show you how
and it's creating other people they
actually whenever there's something like
we're talking about drugs or anything
relating things they want
they want the top G
they want the person with the produce
the one that produces all the little
ones the little minions and things like
whether it's drugs they're not going to
go after the little guy even though
there's a lot of people that are selling
the drugs they're gonna go after the top
G and turn these little ones
against that top one so we can get the
top one
that's good that's gonna that's what's
gonna yeah that's what that's gonna
happen and in that case he's the one
that's creating other people so of
course they're going after him I'll say
this that's a really good question I'm
charged with being the head of an
organized criminal Group which is in
charge of recruiting girls to make Tick
Tock videos they face charges which
include human trafficking and forming a
criminal gang to sexually exploit the
only fans is the best hustle in the
world they're accusing me of using the
Loverboy method coercing them by being
nice I wasn't sure about some of the
other charges but just listening to how
little regard he has for these people
knowing they would never want to do this
work and manipulating them isolating
from their friends and family making
sure that they got zero access to money
using every tactic in the book to
dehumanize them and make sure they're
the lowest or the lows it wouldn't
surprise me if he raped them
you know what I'm saying I'm not saying
it did happen but considering how he
talks about Georgina considering the
text that they said about her
threatening these women with violence
right
he's directly responsible for that the
same way when they come after a criminal
organization the head boss is
responsible for what the lackeys do
right that's why when they bring a RICO
charge or they're doing something
against organizations everybody going to
jail for the murders right because even
though you didn't do it the people under
you did it for the benefit of the group
Georgina and when she makes those
threats of violence against other people
right she's doing it on behalf of Tate
and his Empire but so he go that's why
they're getting charged as an
organization and if he's the top person
of that organization and they can prove
that yeah well then he's the one that's
going to go down so that's why yep would
you think there would be this much
skepticism or this much weirdness about
the whole thing if this was children
involved
isolating them doing all this stuff
no
can I ask you and let's say you're right
you know what let me let me concede to
you guys let's say they aren't
sympathetic victims and they shouldn't
be sympathetic that's fine just because
they're not should we not charge the
person who's scamming and defrauding
them
the person who's luring them in with
promises and marriages and doing all
this to try to push them into a
life that they want yeah right
Destiny say that but he's just like you
know older people should know better but
they still are the ones most likely to
be scammed by psychics and everything
else
should we abandon them to the scammers
just because they should have known
better not we should go as cameras
because cameras are going to scam and if
that's what they do I'm just saying I
don't understand this line of like
thinking either where is this these
women are clearly being victimized by
someone who's trying to them over
and defrauding them okay stealing their
money in their income and over time I
just build up this big this big Little
Empire of webcam girls at one one point
I had four locations 75 girls working
for me I'd take around half of the money
around 50 take 50 around 50 they thought
they were on 50 percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes self-admittedly
right luring them away from their
friends and family and doing all this
stuff and promising life of marriage
which that's trafficking we should still
charge them irrespective of whether or
not these women were gullible or not
and if it was a man in this situation
being Lord I would want the same thing
but that's me yeah but bro they're
gold diggers